be your host for this presentation
before i introduce our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about agilent
and our products for cell analysis
agilent as a leader in life sciences is
very focused on enabling our customers
to gain the insights they seek our
rapidly growing cell analysis portfolio
enables deeper
more reliable insights across a variety
of cell analysis applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand dynamic
cellular environments and interactions
this is critically important for
advancing applied
translational research on vaccine
development
and autoimmune disease
where a more comprehensive understanding
of host pathogen effects and mechanisms
of immune system function
and response is required
our presentations today will speak
specifically to how our solutions are
being employed in that context
i'm very excited to have with us today
our speaker dr
shannon russell shannon completed her
phd in dr brett finley's lab at the
university of british columbia in 2014.
her phd work focused on examining the
role of antibiotic use in early life
its impact on the gastrointestinal
microbiome and how gut microbes
affect susceptibility the gut and lung
inflammatory disease
in 2015 shannon moved to south africa to
do a postdoc with dr adrie stein in tv
research
at the welcome trust hhmi funded africa
health research institute in serbian
shannon currently works at the british
columbia center for disease control as a
research associate where she is involved
in a variety of genomics projects
that improve outbreak surveillance in
the province
including integrating stars coveted to
genomics into british columbia's covid19
public health response
for the presentation today we are also
joined with an introduction by dr
adrie stein who is a leader in
infectious disease research
adrie heads up the lab at the africa
health research institute
and also retains a position and research
program at the university of alabama in
birmingham
the africa health research institute is
a multi-disciplinary
independent research institute based
across two sites in the province of
kwazulu-natal south africa
the goal of the institute because of its
proximity to hiv and tb
is aimed to support and facilitate
discoveries into the susceptibility
of transmission and cure of these
diseases
but before i hand it over to adrie a
couple of housekeeping notes
there will be a question and answer
period immediately following the talk
and to help us get to as many of your
questions as possible
we encourage you to type in your
questions during the presentation
we will also meet in our networking
lounge at the conclusion of this webinar
to further discuss
topics presented today with additional
experts from the field
we hope you will join our specialists
here or visit us in the exhibit hall
and with that i will hand it over the
presentation to dr adrie stein
thank you very much heather for the
introduction i have one single slide
and in this slide i will describe uh our
future interest
and the current ongoing projects in the
laboratory
hi aj we seem to have lost your audio
connection
we'll give adrie just a moment to um
hopefully call back in
um let's let's see it looks like we are
having some
technical difficulties that are
that are uh being resolved at the moment
so we'll give adrie just a minute
here to um
to log back in thanks for your patience
so just a a reminder that we um we're
having some technical audio issues with
adrian
uh and so we're not able to hear his
introduction to the presentation
we um what we what we may do here is
actually just
move ahead to um to shannon's
presentation so shannon's
shannon russell is going to be um
going to be leading the uh the majority
of the talk today so we'll give
just a minute for the slides to advance
to that point
hi heather all right so with that let's
hand it over to shannon to begin her
portion of the presentation
okay um
let me just see
i'm seeing a different cover slide here
just move through audrey's
okay perfect thanks shannon thanks to
the audience there we go you're patient
there we go all right okay
it's going back
um yeah unfortunately we lost audrey
um must be the south african connection
quite a ways away um
but thank you heather for the kind
introduction
um i'm really looking forward to
having the opportunity to share some of
the research i was working on in south
africa
i'm just going back here so can everyone
see the cover slide there
going back
okay so in the work i'll present today
i hope to convince you that by applying
a metabolic lens to host pathogen
interactions
and host immunity you can gain some
interesting new perspectives and
identify new types of interventions
to treat an old
pathogen like mycobacterium tuberculosis
okay
just keeps going back to slide seven
all right um well i wanted to briefly
uh touch on a bit of background of my
mycobacterium
tuberculosis so unlike
our pathogen like you know an emerging
pathogen like covid19
mycobacterium tuberculosis has plagued
humans for more than 100 years
and what i think is really fascinating
about it um
is that it's a very old bug but it still
perplexes us today because of some of
its unique properties as a pathogen
it's extremely slow growing and it has
an
unusually hardy cell wall
this means that it can hang around in
the environment for a significant amount
of time
the month or possibly years waiting for
an opportune host
so
because these of these properties tb
still remains the top infectious disease
killer in the world
in 2018 there were 10 million new cases
and 1.5 million deaths
to put things into perspective these
numbers currently
exceed covid however they are
disproportionately distributed
amongst low-income countries
the most pressing concern is the
emergence of drug resistance strains
mdr and xdr multi-drug resistant and
extensively drug resistant
strains of mtb they're becoming
increasingly problematic
and they account for the largest number
of deaths due to amr
in the world
this is just a snapshot from the global
tuberculosis report put out by the who
in 2020
and it really shows that sub-saharan
african countries have the highest rates
of tb per capita
along with parts of southeast asia
tb is the highest in these areas
because of the hiv and tb co-epidemic
so for the rest of the talk i'm going to
zoom in to the southern tip of africa to
show you
more about tuberculosis in south africa
so in 2015 i had the pleasure of joining
dr
stain's research group at the
prestigious africa health research
institute in durban
to address some very important pertinent
questions about tb disease development
in an area of the world that continues
to be deeply impacted by amrtv
so i know that audrey was going to share
some examples of
some of the um really incredible into
interdisciplinary and cutting-edge work
that goes on
at ari i did have a slide here but i
took it out because he was going to
discuss it a little bit more
but they do some incredible work um
with different populations in the area
and a lot of really truly translational
translational work so we'll talk a
little bit about that at the end
um and
so this is the africa health research
institute and
it's located in in durban
so a little bit about tb in south africa
south africa has the fourth highest
burden of drug resistant tb in the world
durban and the province of cuisine
has the highest burden of xcr tv in
sub-saharan africa
and 60 of tb patients are actually
co-infected with hiv
hence the co-epidemic it's estimated
that over half of the population in
south africa is believed to be latently
infected
with mtv so that those numbers look like
55.2 percent of the population which is
huge what we see is that there's about a
50
cure rate for tb including drug
susceptible strains in south africa
and this uh should be much higher but
uh you know part of it is due to access
to care
which remains a key public health
challenge so access to tb diagnostics
and tv treatment is particularly
difficult
in in rural communities
one of the few areas of the world where
um
lung resection surgeries remain part of
the standard of care to extend
lives of patients with severe tb disease
so this is something that
audrey would probably have touched on in
his intro
is he has some incredible relationships
with lung pathologists
and thoracic surgeons in durban where
they do lung resections on a daily basis
to extend the lives of patients with
amrtb
and they
they work together to try to understand
a lot of the pathology that happens
in tb disease with respect to
amr and drug susceptible strains so so
they
they get a lot of these freshly resected
lungs that come into the lab
to do sort of further research
investigations on them
and so to digress a little bit
i was gonna go into the science and chat
a little bit about
uh the ingenuity of mtb
and its ability to evade the host immune
system this is one of the reasons why
we still struggle to find
ways to treat tbs because it's
it's an incredible pathogen so there's
essential dogma
which exists and it's a very simplified
model where
an individual would would breathe in
a microbacterium tuberculosis bacterium
and this bacteria would then be taken up
by a lung resident macrophage
a cd4 t cell an antigen specific c where
t
cell would then interact with this
macrophage
producing interferon gamma and tnf
alpha to actually induce the
antimicrobial activity
of the macrophage and theoretically that
macrophage because i'm
kill mtb and all would be good but
in fact it's a lot more complex than
that
and so this review
um figure from nunes
alves in 2014 illustrates it really
nicely in that
that that was sort of the central dogma
which involved the macrophage and the
cd4 t
cell but now this this dogma
has been revised to include a lot of
other
different uh immune cells
and specifically t cells but also
neutrophils
and a lot of different inflammatory
mediators so there's a lot of
different things happening here um
and a lot of different cell types that
play important roles in tb immunity
so of course adding to that layer of
complexity
is that all of this happens in the
context of a tb
granuloma which is in itself an
architectural wonder
so here is
a pathology slide from
a patient with pulmonary tb and this is
sort of zoomed in on one of the tv
granulomas
in the lung and the cells that are
stained
brown are cda t cells
so you can see those cd8 t cells
decorated on the outside of that tb
granuloma
and i think looking at this slide was
really interesting
to me and this is sort of where the
hypothesis was generated
um when i arrived in the lab was that
you know the central dogma that involves
just cd4 t cells
there's just no way that you know cd4 t
cells are the only
t cells involved in the tb immune
response
those cd8 t cells are clearly there
decorated on the outside of that
granuloma why are they there and are
they
are they functioning effectively
is there something about that granuloma
that
the granuloma micro environment that is
restricting productive t cell responses
because essentially what's inside the
center of that granuloma
are the tb bacilli macrophage is another
necrotic material so how can those
t-cells
effectively do the killing that they're
meant to do
so far away from the source of infection
so that
i guess begs the question is the
granuloma and micro environment
restricting productive t cell responses
due to reduced availability of nutrients
it's all about nutrients or at least
that's what we
um hypothesized so
all right just a little bit about uh
cd8t cell responses and tb disease
what's interesting is that
humans fail to generate robust cv8
t-cell memory during mtb infection
tb patients do not develop protective
immunity to re-infection
is this partly due to the lack of a cd8
t cell response um and
most existing tb vaccine candidates
generate
poor cb t cell responses is just one of
the reasons
why we have not yet identified
an effective tb vaccine could be one of
the reasons
so does failure to develop lasting
mtb specific cd8 t cell responses
contribute to
mtb persistence
and that was basis of our central
hypothesis
which is that mtv maintains persistence
during chronic infection by inducing
environmental cues that lead
to the metabolic and functional
deterioration
of mtb specific cd8 t cell responses
in the host so
we have an effector t cell that should
be very energetic
metabolically has increased cytokine
production
lots of proliferation and growth and is
capable of clearing a pathogen
but what happens in the context of a tb
granuloma
could that microenvironment within the
tb granuloma
actually be limiting productive t cell
responses
leading to an exhausted t cell for
example or a quiescent
t cell with reduced proliferation and
growth
with mitochondrial dysfunction and hence
decreased
cytokine production so effects
effectively
that t cell which you know should have
been
metabolically ramped up and ready to
to fight and instead it you know becomes
exhausted and ineffective
so we wanted to look at that in the
context of a mouse model
and and i suppose you know
if we're able to characterize that shift
in metabolic reprogramming
could we then reverse it with some sort
of host directed therapy
to to rejuvenate the
metabolism of that t cell
and that is something this host directed
therapy is is something that
you know is is receiving a lot of
attention in other fields for example
cancer
being one of them other chronic viral
infections like hepatitis
so could we apply a similar
thought process to tb
so this is the experiment we did
we had uh it was a three-month
experiment where
we would infect mice
with um either h-37rv
our pathogenic pb strain
or the non-pathogenic
vaccine strain bcg
so we are interested essentially in in
comparing the lung resident
cd8 t cell populations in two different
infection models
one pathogenic mtb with non-pathogenic
bcg so what we did was we infected mice
using the chronic model which is only
100 cfus
via the aerosol route and
we had three experimental time points
two which were considered early time
points and
one considered late so the early time
points were day 21 and day 35 post
infection
and the late time point was at week 12.
so about three months later and at each
of those three time points
we looked at a couple different
parameters we looked at
bioenergetics we looked at uh
the cell myostress test and the
glycolysis stress test
which i will describe to you a little
bit later we looked at metabolomics
so we did some looking at
central carbon metabolism using
c13 incorporation as well as atp
adp and amp ratios and then we also did
a lot of flow cytometry to look at
glucose uptake
mitochondrial fitness and cytokine
secretion
so the graph you see um at the bottom
is charting the
the lung bacilli over time
for that model so from day 21 day 35 to
week 12
you can see that you know even though
we're infecting with 100 cf youth
the mtb pathogenic mycobacteria
seem to be much larger
in numbers in the lungs of the mice
compared to bcg infection
so so i guess that that leads us to the
question do these infections
knowing that we have a difference in
bacterial burn in the lungs
differentially
alter the metabolism of the lungs cv8 t
cells so
is there an effect on
t cell metabolism
so the first thing we wanted to look at
were actually inhibitory inhibitory
receptor expression
because these markers have been linked
to t cell exhaustion
cd1 ctla4 are
two inhibitory receptors linked to
functional t cell exhaustion and klrg1
is a terminal differentiation marker
we also we're interested in looking at
and all three of these have actually
been shown to be upregulated
on the surface of t cells from patients
with tb we wanted to look at those in
the context of our model
and compare the mtb infected mice to
bcg infected mice and then
obviously compared to uninfected so just
quickly the blue bars are
pd8t cell populations from uninfected
mice and these are these are all
uh lungs 88 t cells
the green um our cd8 t cells
from the lung of bcg infected mice
red from mtb infected mice
and the orange is actually
mtv specific uh cda t-cells so we used
a tb 10.4 tetramer to
to look specifically at
t cells that we knew were mtp specific
so
that just gives you a comparison to
the total cd8 population
so we found that indeed those
inhibitory receptors were increased in
expression
um as well as klrg1
specifically or i guess most pronounced
in those mtb specific t-cell populations
that we looked at
so the orange bars
then we looked at
glucose uptake so there had been some
literature
showing that
[Music]
pd1 one of the inhibitory receptors
actually is linked to
decreased glycolytic capacity in
exhausted t
cells so we want to know
because we see this increase in
inhibitory receptor expression do we
also see a decrease in glucose uptake in
these cells
and indeed we do so you see the bottom
left hand
graph you see
mtb and the mtb specific t
cells have significantly lower
mean fluorescence intensity of two and
bdg which indicates
that their glucose uptake is
significantly lower than
uh cd8 t cells from uninfected or bcg
infected animals and then the histograms
on the right
show just that that same bar graph but
reflected in histogram so over time we
see that histogram
shifting back towards
um towards
our control which is no to nbcd um
and those mtb specific t cells
really have a pronounced decrease in
glucose uptake
so knowing that we have
this increase in inhibitory expression
uh inhibitory receptor expression
and this decrease in glucose uptake we
wanted to
examine these cda t cell populations
using extracellular metabolic flux
analysis
i don't know i wasn't sure how much
detail to give here because i imagine
there's a lot of experts in the audience
but essentially
xf analysis is an incredible technology
that can measure
two parameters simultaneously the
mitochondrial respiration and glycolytic
function
in real time and so
below is a diagram of aerobic
respiration
in the mammalian cell and
just showing that the xf analyzer can in
fact
measure two things simultaneously the
oxygen
consumption rate or ocr which is an
indicator of oxidative phosphorylation
and extracellular acidification rate
which is a proxy for glycolysis
so if you are
an xf pro you already know all of this
um
but basically the beauty is that you can
create a cell monolayer
with any cell type of interest in my
case it was
about 250 000 cda t
cells per well purified the from the
lungs of
infected mice and what you can do is
analyze a number of different biogenic
bioenergetic parameters
at once by injecting different
metabolism altering compounds
into the cell medium using the four
drug ports shown there in the figure
you have a lot of flexibility in your
assay
based on the type of compounds that you
inject
um to shift metabolism in different ways
so there were two key bioenergetic
assays that we used
um to measure t cell bioenergetics in
vivo
in these infected mice and one of them
was the cell mind of stress test
which measures mitochondrial respiration
and the cell's ability to cope under
mitochondrial stress and to those of you
who are new
to this technology
once you create your cell monolayer you
then
inject three inhibitor
three inhibitor combinations
one being oligomycin
which is an inhibitor of atp synthase so
if you look um at the graph or the the
figure below
you have uh the electron transport chain
and so that oligomycin in fact blocks
adp synthase which provides an estimate
of mitochondrial derived atp production
then we inject a compound called ftcp
which is a mitochondrial uncoupler
it pushes the cell to its maximum
respiratory capacity
or mrc and it allows protons to flow
through the mitochondrial membrane
unrestricted
then we inject a rotanoin and antimycin
a
which actually effectively shuts down
the
electron transport chain revealing any
non-mitochondrial oxygen consumption so
we get this really nice
cmst profile shown uh
in the graph on the upper left-hand side
so you can measure those different
parameters based on
yeah your your drugs that you've
injected
so this gives you a real
real insight into the mitochondrial
health
of your cells
so another thing that we use is a
bioenergetic xenogram
which is plotting oxygen consumption
rate as a function
of extracellular acidification rate
it can be used to illustrate the energy
phenotype of your cell particular
cell population of interest so whether
your cell
is more glycolytic more energetic
aerobic or coriscent depending on the
ratio
of your ocr to ecar well
it gives you a really nice visual of
where your cell type fits
in relation to others if you're trying
to compare different cell populations or
the same cell population in different
conditions
which is what we were interested in
essentially looking at these different
uh cdh t cell populations from
mtb or bcg infected mice
so these are our results
and i'm showing you the time points day
21
day 35 and week 12.
what you see is that bcg and mtb have
comparable cmsd profiles as day 21 post
infection
so overall they are less energetic than
uninfected cells
but at day 35 bcg cells are
regaining their respiratory capacity
and at week 12 these cd8 t cells from
mdb infected mice are in fact
kind of flatlining you can see that
they're really
at the low end of that um
graph they have very little
basal or resting ocr
and they have very little maximum
respiratory capacity
when fccp is added
and then you can actually see so
at that week 12 time point i have added
uh the tb 10.4 tetramer cells so these
are the mtb
specific t cells
just as a comparison to to total cd8 t
cells from the infected mice i was only
able to capture
that particular cell population at the
week 12 time point
because you need a ton of cells and
it was only at that chronic stage did i
have enough
t cells to actually do the analysis so
that's why you don't see
that same cell type in the day 21 or the
day 35 time point
so underneath the cmst profiles
we have the bioenergetic phenograms
displayed
underneath that correspond with each of
the different time points
and you know the same trends you'll you
see the same trends essentially
at day 21 there's really no difference
in the energetic profile of the mtb
infected mice compared to bcg
but then at day 35 and week 12 there's
this separation
between the different infections and
quite a massive gap between the
mtb infected mice and
bcd and uninfected
cva t cells compared
at the week 12 time point so
those this suggests that um
there's really a significant drop
in uh the bioenergetic capacity of these
cells from mtb infected mice
at the chronic stage so at week 12.
and you know
i guess essentially what does this mean
um
we found it really interesting so so
next
we wanted to do
a t-cell activation assay we wanted to
compare
what would happen when we to those
t-cells you know in their excess plate
when we activate them with anti-cd3 and
dcd28
coated beads to measure the level of t
cell activation
in response to these activator beads so
how
how do the bioenergetics compare
unactivate in their unactivated state
compared to the activated state
and you can see on the left hand side of
that graph
the the round circles
indicate unactivated t cells
from each of the groups uninfected bcg
infected or mtb
and the squares indicate
uh you know we've added those activation
beads and now we're measuring
the bio inject bioenergetics of these
cells
after activation
so you do see an increase in
the energetic state of these cells in
every case
however uh the
the parameters are different or or
you know when we compare so so if you
look at the
bar graph on the right hand side
i show you specifically ocr and ecar
and what we found uh was that
the south um from mtb infected mice
they they seemed to be their glycol
their glycolysis seemed fine so their
glycolytic capacity
uh seemed functional they were able to
to ramp up glycolysis
in response to these activator beads um
no problem but
when we looked at ocr and i'm just going
to highlight it here
the ocr barely changed at all
compared to our uninfected mice and our
bacg
infected mice which suggest that there
could be a defect in mitochondrial
metabolism
so those cells you know before and after
activation
really didn't change uh their oxygen
consumption rate at all compared to the
other cell types
that was really interesting to us
so we thought you know
based on what we observed there
you know is there some defect in the
mitochondria
is there a reason is there a drop in the
right the mitochondrial health
of these cva t cells during chronic mtb
infection so we did flow cytometry
to to look at to zoom in on those
mitochondria basically
we found that dysfunctional mitochondria
accumulate
in those cda t cells during chronic
infection
and so the way we looked at that uh was
on let's see so so the graph on the left
the top
left shows you the percentage of
depolarized mitochondria in each of
those
cd8 t cell populations over time
and what we found the way we measured
that
was using two mitochondrial dyes mito
mido tracker deep red and miter tracker
green which is actually shown to you
in the scatter plot at the bottom so if
we look at those two parameters
side by side we can actually pull out
those
cells that actually have depolarized
mitochondria or or thick mitochondria
and those cells are indicated by
the triangle there they have
um higher miter tracker green but
lower mida tracker deep red miter
tracker deep red
um is able to stain for
mitochondrial membrane potential and
mitochondria green
stains for mitochondrial mass so we're
selecting for cells
that have an increased mitochondrial
mass and a decreased mitochondrial
membrane potential
so in addition to those depolarized
mitochondria another
feature of dysfunctional mitochondria is
uh an increase in mitosox um
or in other words um mitochondrial
reactive oxygen species
mitochondrial roth so we did an assay
using this mitosox dye to show that
in fact those mitochondria are producing
a lot more
[Music]
roth which also could
be an indicator of mitochondrial
dysfunction
so knowing that we see these trends in
the mtb infected mice um
that it appears that there is this
mitochondrial dysfunction which is then
you know having an effect on
mitochondrial respiration
and mitochondrial metabolism could we
then
use a drug uh that
targets mitochondrial metabolism to
actually
you know shift these cells or or
reinvigorate
uh mitochondrial metabolism in these
cells
so we're interested in looking at uh
host directed therapy
and
this so i've just shown you here this is
a really nice review
which has been published by robert
mahon and richard hafner of the division
of aids
and they propose you know there's a
number of different post-directed
therapeutic targets that are fda
approved
that are being used for
or sorry host directed i guess therapies
that target specific regulatory
molecules
are many of them involved in metabolism
that are being
you know explored for for other diseases
like cancer
or other chronic viral infections
and could we potentially repurpose these
drugs
for mycobacterium tuberculosis
host directed therapy they could be used
you know as an adjunct
treatment to existing mtv therapy for
example
to shorten treatment time this this is a
nice paper sort of
going through different types of
post-directed
therapeutic drugs that you know could
have an effect
on tuberculosis
and so one of the compounds that came to
our attention was
metformin and metformin is
um it's a widely used diabetic drug
and it targets the ampk mtor
access of energy nutrient sensors that
control metabolism
and sorry in mammalian cells
depending on the concentration also
targets
gap dh and
recently it was published uh this is
actually from 2014 now
uh that it could that metformin could be
a potential adjunct therapy
for tb this paper
showed in mice that it was able to
synergistically
uh re further reduce uh bacillary
burn and mice infected with mtb
so we
sorry okay so we wanted to to look at
metformin
um in our mouth model so this is
this is the experiment we did um a
similar chronic infection
uh you know as i showed you before with
h37 rv
our lab strain uh pathogenic
mycobacteria
and we then treated mice
from day seven post-infection all the
way to day 35
500 milligrams per kg
daily uh in an oral format
and we looked at two time points day 21
and
day 35 we looked at sort of similar
uh similar assays as before so
for fluid cytometry and we're also
interested in looking at survival
um as far as cfus and then one pathology
so we've got um this is these are one of
this is one of the
uh results that we noticed uh was that
metformin actually increases the
abundance of mtb
specific cva t cells in the lungs so
those
that proportion of mtb specific t cells
actually
doubles both in the lung and spleen of
these mice treated with metformin that
was interesting to us
so all of a sudden they're producing
more cd8 t
cells but what about um
what about the metabolism of those t
cells do we actually see metformin
impacting the
cd8t cell bioenergetics
and although we didn't see any real
changes at day 21
we found some really interesting changes
of day 35
post infection you will see
that in the cmst profile here
those cd8 t cells
from mice that were treated with
metformin
actually have a lot large
they have increased basal ocr but then
they also have
increased maximum respiratory capacity
and spare respiratory capacity so those
cells that you see in purple we're
actually looking at the purple line
compared to
the red line there there's a massive
increase in the respiratory capacity
the mitochondrial metabolism of these
cells
and that shift is also demonstrated in
the phenogram shown on your right hand
side
where cells you know that were
essentially
quiescent they had a more of a quiescent
energy phenotype
had become more energetic and i guess
another thing to note is the comparison
between
the blue and the green dots
or lines depending on which graph you
look at we can also see that
metformin affects the metabolism of
the cd8 t cells from uninfected mice
but perhaps to a lesser lesser extent or
you know a smaller magnitude
that was really interesting to us we
could really see
that there was uh you know a positive
effect on
mitochondrial metabolism upon metformin
treatment in these mice
um yeah so
that so say i guess thinking about the
broader implications of the work
um you know improving the metabolic
health of cda t
cells during mtb infection has the
potential to alter downstream
inflammatory signaling pathways it could
lead to a reduction in lung damage by
limiting excessive airway inflammation
perhaps it could enhance
the survival or fitness of effector t
cells required for control
of mtb um but it can also
bolster re-resistance to reinfection by
facilitating the generation of
long-lived memory cells we know um
from the pierce group that cd8t
cell or cd8 memory cells
they have incredible
mitochondrial respiration
they have really high spare respiratory
capacity
and and they need that in order to
survive for a really long time
so you know could
an intervention like metformin actually
make these t-cells uh more robust and
and you know capable of long-lived
memory
so more importantly what happens in
human pulmonary tb
and i want to just give you a quick
snapshot of you know some of the work
that is happening
in durban in uh audrey stain's lab
and i'm yeah really only gonna give you
just a snippet of it there's
a ton more and it's really interesting
um but
i wanted to talk to you briefly about
this report essay study um
and at the moment actually
i need to check check with audrey there
could be many more patients enrolled at
this point
i think um at the time that i was there
the sample size
of 100 patients and they were looking
specifically at
adults with drug susceptible tb
and this study had
three specific aims they wanted to look
at neutrophil phenotypic markers in
peripheral blood
phenotypic drug tolerance in speedum
and measure well the third specific aim
was measure the bioenergetic health
of monocytes and lymphocytes in
peripheral blood and so i think that
third specific aim was
what audrey's lab is really focusing on
and where they remember the study role
it was rolled out in 2017.
so some of the work that they've done
uh let me just move slides here
this was a clinical study that took
place
in multiple medical clinics in durban
and essentially at the time tb treatment
was prescribed the patient was enrolled
and blood was drawn
for a time zero measurement these
patients were then followed up at two
months and six months and i actually
believe that there is a 12 month
time point here which isn't on the side
with a blood draw and that that
peripheral
blood was then purified for monocytes
and lymphocytes
and run on the extracellular flux
analysis instrument to measure their
bioenergetic capacity
in real time so the goal of this
arm of the study was to understand
whether measuring the cellular
metabolism
of circulating monocytes and lymphocytes
can be used as a biomarker to predict
tb treatment outcomes
and this is just one side to quickly
show
what they uh what they found and
i think it's really fascinating um
basically
those and this is just looking at
lymphocytes um
so at time zero before tb treatment
those uh those t cells
were basically flat lining they had very
little bioenergetic capacity left in
them
and as treatment progressed we could
actually see
that um the spare respiratory capacity
of those cells
vastly improved you can see that the
cmsd profile on the left hand side
it's amazing the difference um at that
six month mark
that was observed
in in a number of patients and you can
see on
the dot plot on the right hand side
i'm looking at multiple patients over
time there is definitely a trend
of improved spare respiratory capacity
among these lymphocytes as
treatment progresses so as
the outcome improves
for these tb patients and all of this
work
was done by dr bridget cummings and the
technician
in the lab calvin atticott and there
could be others at this point
that i haven't mentioned and i apologize
there's a credible amount of work
that has gone into this and they will
have a really
i know that they've got a a really nice
story
um that they will be showing you you
know very soon
so that's just a snippet of what they
found there
really showing the translation of our
animal work
and the application of that looking at
you know
patient population with tb um
you know and the impact that tb
treatment has
on improving the biogenic capacity
of lymphocytes in the blood
so in summary i will go through this
quickly because i believe
time is flying by what have i told you
today
basically that cd8 t cells from
mtb infected animals have increased
expression
of markers associated with t cell
exhaustion
and they have decreased glucose uptake
mitochondrial bioenergetics deteriorates
in those cd8 t cells as chronic mtb
infection progresses
dysfunctional mitochondria to
accumulate in cda t cells from mtb
infected animals
when we compare mtb and bcg infections
this provides a lot of insight into how
metabolism may be involved in the
development of protective versus
pathogenic immunity
metformin host directed therapy has the
potential to rejuvenate
mitochondrial metabolism in t cells from
mtb infected mice
there's much more we could do here to
expand on that
as far as future experiments which we
can
definitely discuss um and and then
measuring the bioenergetic health of t
cells can be profoundly linked
to disease progression and the response
to tb
treatment so all that leaving you
with um
the thought that you know measuring t
cell immune metabolism in tbs
is really valuable
and you know it really opens up the door
to many future host directed therapy
targets
you could be used as a biomarker
or you know bioenergetics
or type of bioenergetic assay could be
used to measure
something like vaccine efficacy for new
tb
vaccine trials
that is the end just wrap up by saying
that
you know this extracellular flux
analysis
analysis can really be applied to
advancing our understanding of host
pathogen interactions
and you know i think that this is
it's an incredible application uh for
really
expanding our knowledge of infectious
diseases
and i would highly recommend it as a
tool so
i need to there's there's many many
shout outs there's so many people that
helped
with this work you know we had many many
late nights in the lab
uh something i didn't touch on but one
one and two was
the actual um the amount of work that it
takes
to do these type of analyses in the
biosafety
level three environment is huge and i
couldn't have done it
without all of these people in the in
the steam lab
dirk lamprek bridgette cummings ages
ramen terence jones
uh james matarotti rakia
kelvin vanessa everybody uh it was such
a team effort
um and as well as the animals uh
care core siobhan and magani
and i have to thank obviously
audrey for being my mature in all of
this and providing so many
um fascinating insights
and teaching me all about metabolism
because i was completely new to the
field
back in 2015. so um and there's there's
ton of
tons of funding there that also needs to
be recognized the
national research foundation the mrc
south africa
department of defense uh nih
hhmi as well as the welcome trust
so so with that i'm happy to
answer any questions that anyone might
have
thank you for your attention
oh my goodness thank you so much shannon
for such a wonderful presentation this
was
really really interesting um and again
thanks to our audience today for your
patience with uh the
technical difficulties that occurred at
the beginning i believe we have
audrey back on the line um so
unfortunately we
are not able to get his introduction but
he's definitely been a huge part of this
project
as well but great job shannon
so we we do have just a couple minutes
left
and we do have a number of questions so
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar uh have time for a question or
two
if just to remind you if you have a
question you'd like to ask please submit
it
we'll be able to get one or two
questions before the end of the hour
but however if we don't make it to your
question we will
uh be able to forward them on to our
speaker and the agilent team to follow
up with you
so um we'll just hop in and um also to
remind you that
we will have um a networking room after
this so we'll be a networking lounge so
we'll be able to meet and follow up with
some additional
chats in there but um getting to a
question or two
um on the top before we close so
um i just wanted to comment shannon you
showed some incredibly interesting data
on sort of the response of spare
respiratory capacity and mitochondrial
function to
chronic disease uh progression with
respect to like
lymphocyte exhaustion so that's
something that i
i just wanted to call that out because
there's been a tremendous amount of
interest around that lately and sort of
the applications there
do you um so now getting to the question
do you have any sense of whether bio
bioenergetics or even any other
biomarkers could
essentially be used to predict
vulnerability or susceptibility to tb
infection and disease progression so in
this case you showed it as
sort of a marker for disease progression
but the question is really getting more
at looking at
someone who is not infected and how they
may actually respond to infection as a
kind of a vulnerability
that's an excellent question i i would
say absolutely
um we already know that uh
you know going back to tb i guess
specifically
there are a number of uh
metabolic disorders that actually
increase the risk of tb
and so we think that you know having
these types of metabolic disorders
will then obviously affect the
metabolism of your immune system
and will increase or make you you know
more vulnerable
to tb disease progression
so so there is evidence there
certainly epidemiologically but then
also
you know looking at um sort of
well specifically that paper that i
mentioned from 2014
with metformin they did do
a clinical piece where they actually
looked at
patients who are on tb treatment as well
as getting metformin for
uh for their diabetes and they they saw
there was an improvement
in in those individuals
over um you know people who are not
on that type of uh metabolic treatment
so
so we think that you know there's
definitely a relationship there
so thank you for relying on that
what's up oh i didn't know if audrey
wanted to comment further i mean
that was a great response also we'll
have time to follow up um in the
networking
room as well um if you're able to make
it
so i'll just close with one kind of a
follow-up sort of question on that
um can you do you have any thoughts on
the mechanisms behind the mitochondrial
function that we're seeing
associated with this tb infection do you
think of it as
any thoughts on if it's like a direct
cause or effect or any
mechanisms at play there ah
that's a very good question that is
something i think we definitely wanted
to follow up with
um after this uh publication
i think it's i don't know if audrey has
has an opinion on this but i
in my mind i see it as a a nutrient
deficiency or something something that
has to do with that micro environment
where uh you know within the tv
granuloma and i think that
um i don't think that the mtb
specifically
uh so the bacterium itself is having a
direct effect on the t
cells i think it's literally the
environment that it creates within that
tb
granuloma uh you know there's probably
there's probably a direct effect
um mtv on the macrophages
and potentially um you know because
audrey's lab uh bridget specifically has
shown that there's
um an interaction or actually uh there's
no
there's an effect from mtv infected
macrophages on the macrophage metabolism
and so it could be an indirect effect of
that
uh you know metabolic shift in
the macrophage metabolism that is
actually having an effect
then downstream on the t cells that are
coming into the site of infection
and i think that's sort of that's
similar to the behavior of a tumor cell
and these tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
where the tumor itself creates this
highly glycolytic environment that is
really nutrient depletes
and those t cells coming into the
environment become polarized and
you know ineffective at what they're
meant to be doing because
of that nutrient familiar um in the
surrounding environment so i think it's
it's really interesting
much more work that needs to be done
there
yeah i think that's a really great
answer on that um
some just some thoughts about kind of
the comparison between the
tumor and micro environment really
interesting
amazing presentation um great q a
that we had time for so i'm just seeing
that we're a couple of minutes over
what um i just want to thank you again
shannon and
adrie for sharing your work with us
today um
sorry again the technical issues thanks
to the audience for your patience
and questions and participation so now
if you would like to continue your
questions and discussion
uh with shannon and adrie then please
join us in our networking lounge
and you can do so by clicking um in the
discuss
presentation topics and more poster on
the right of your screen or by clicking
the networking lounge button at the
bottom of
your screen so thanks every thanks very
much everyone and we'll hope to see you
over in that networking lounge
have a great day everyone thanks shannon
thank you
bye
you